hello and welcome to the Tata Steel
rapid and blitz opening ceremony we are
here at the Taj Mahal the official hotel
of the Grantchester
India leg the players are all here they
are ready to kick off the drawing of
lots there is an excitement in the air
but they're still pretty calm and social
and having a good time with each other
but that's not going to last long
because the adrenalin has already kicked
in the stakes are high let's get this
started we had the first tata steel test
india repeatin blitz tournament last
year it was a huge success and now we
are even growing because we are part of
the grand Chester and I can assure you
it's a very interesting event because
some players are still trying to qualify
for the last spot in London so there is
something at stake in this tournament I
want to start with a big thank you to
all the top players making it and coming
here and creating such a wonderful
atmosphere for chess
and all the best to all of you who have
taken our time to come and be with us in
Kolkata the weather is great and let's
have some good chess thank you so much
that was an amazing opening ceremony
everybody had a great time but now it's
time to get back into the action
[Music]